[Music]
Super Bowl ads one final point Gary buy
them
you got your perspective what's up guys
this is a fun conversation we had the
day after the Super Bowl in New York
City with some great people from Pepsi
and notch and MBC you super excited
about the conversation very macro
branding TV stuff that I think is a
different look for some of you but
there's some damat ik senate that could
be unbelievably valuable so some
thoughtful branding and marketing talk
hope you enjoy it
despite any controversies advertisers
are flocking to the Superbowl to get
their brand messages across it's
reported that CBS made 382 million
dollars at 5 million per 30-second ad
and it's not surprising because three
out of four people say they look forward
to the Superbowl ads and research shows
that memorability for brands in the
Super Bowl are 54% higher than regular
television norms so it's really a great
place to put your ads regardless and
we're gonna talk a little bit about that
today you know people are talking about
them still they're watching them on
YouTube and so we want to talk about
what is the impact that the Superbowl
has for ads today using some of the the
knotch
research that measured these ads and the
positive impact or negative impact that
people felt about them so the first
question I'm gonna ask is to start maybe
you guys can guess if we missed 3000
people in our industry ranked the ads
can anyone guess what was the number one
ad don't be shy it's okay
out of those twelve or all the ones that
additively I guess
so it was Amazon not everything makes
the cut and next up was the Gillette we
believe the math s men can be as a
matter of fact all the ads measured
mostly had positive impact and sentiment
except for neutral was Pepsi more than
okay bumble and bond and Viv the pitch
of that was actually the only one that
was negative that was negative oh I'm
sorry that was the only one the last one
that we just saw the mermaids I actually
just realized this is like the third or
fourth time I've seen and I just got the
shark tank thing I didn't I didn't get I
was so confused
sorry okay but why do you think and
maybe on D you can start that the Amazon
and Gillette ranked so highly yeah well
I think just at a high level this is
from a personal standpoint as well as
someone who watches a lot of the ads in
this of the football I thought this year
was really interesting because it felt
like most of the brands played it safe
there was a lot of neutrality actually
in the sentiment that we captured even
though it was property skewing towards
positive I think last year we saw a
bunch of backlash against some of the
advertising that was put out there some
of the brands were trying to take early
a bolder statement using cultural trends
and and different borrowing from the
past of different really great people in
American history and their first sort of
got in trouble on social shortly after
so I think this year we saw a lot of the
brands playing it relatively safe
Gillette I don't think was actually on
the Super Bowl but as you all I'm sure
almost everyone here has heard about the
ad before even walking into this room
and I think really what's what's going
on there is obviously tapping into a
massive revolution that has happened
over the last year I've heard very
polarizing opinions from different
categories of people I think women have
had more
positive reactions then men on average I
think it also depends who Gillette was
trying to to kind of aim towards was it
men of a particular type of belief men
who kind of live in urban areas and have
already been touched by a lot of the
changes that have come with the me2
movement or was it a very different
category of people so I think a lot of
these questions actually pop up for me
I'm kind of the token data nerd on the
panel and I think when we talk about the
Super Bowl what I've noticed is you know
brands don't love hearing about data and
measurement everyone wants to have a
very strong opinion when it comes to
whether it works or not and I think the
bigger question for me which I hope we
can tap into tonight is to figure out
what brands does it make sense for what
type of campaigns does it make sense for
is it a brand awareness is it a reach
goal and then how do you really kind of
follow up that on all the other
platforms that that matter as well which
you know all the digital platforms how
do you make sure that you're creating
more than just this one moment in time
and I'll give you just a quick example
which I was recently approved to use I
was having a conversation with the CMO
of Denny's they did a Super Bowl ad a
few years ago and they were offering
some type of offer they they managed
actually to bring a ton of people into
Denny's as a follow-up to the Super Bowl
so there was like a very significant
impact that they saw and they were able
to deliver on the promise that they made
and the Super Bowl ad but then every
time the same group of people would go
back to Denny's they you know would get
a you know neutrals to negative
experience because they actually haven't
figured out by then how to scale the
rest of the company to the traffic and
the promise that the Super Bowl ad made
so I thought that was a really
interesting example of you know this is
not just a once in a lifetime or once a
year type of thing to do you actually
have to be very thoughtful about how you
use it and how it that integrates not
just with the rest of your marketing but
with the rest of your business so it's
an interesting point because as I was
reading some insights that journalists
were writing about from the Superbowl
advertising one thing that came out and
Gary I'm gonna I'm gonna talk to you
about this one is that many marketers
are using social platforms to extend the
Superbowl and a lot of advertisers
pre-launch the commercials to build up
one example that I thought was really
interesting was that the avocado grows
from Mexico they went to social to
actually make guacamole like a Super
Bowl item that you serve and they sold
50 8.4 million avocados for the Super
Bowl this year and that was before they
even advertised in the Super Bowl so I
mean this is a huge change then ten
years ago and if you could talk a little
bit about I mean I know you did a lot of
work with planters and social impact
before and after if you could talk a
little bit about it how you think it's
changed and what marketers can do to use
social to really you know extend the
life of their Super Bowl investment
Thanks thanks for having us
so from my standpoint it's like why
wouldn't you use tools that are
available to you to drive your business
so social to me is a slang term for the
current state of where people spend
their time on the internet which is all
about attention right like what's the
purpose of these ads like like awareness
or attention is that's the best part
about the Superbowl right like you're
gonna get consumption like to me it's
why it's my favorite piece of
advertising in the world like in the US
excuse me like it is going to get
consumed whether on YouTube the week
before whether during the game whether
the next day this is going to get
consumed so that's exciting and then to
not use social as a matter of fact I
actually think brands should really
consider not showing it on YouTube like
for five years I was all about showing
it on YouTube and now I'm wondering if
for next year maybe they shouldn't
because some of the surprise elements
are being eliminated during the game and
I'm just kind of like feeling like is
this the moment like is this the tipping
point where you want to pull back but it
all leads to the biggest punch line
which is these are businesses that are
trying to drive business and this is one
of the opportunities at their disposal
but so is Twitter the week before and so
is pre-roll YouTube the day of and so
I'm fascinated by people's binary points
of view on things it's
obviously a mix of a lot of different
things but this is a cultural event
we're having an event a business event
around it we don't do that for the
Grammys or the Oscars or the NBA Finals
so to me what do I think about I think
anybody who doesn't have a robust
strategy to do creative and media
amplification on the platforms that
dominate our mobile devices is in outer
space in 2019 so you mentioned creative
and yet I mean in this room I'm sure so
many people created ads that they're so
proud of yet there's a lot of ads in the
Superbowl like I'm not sure if anyone
saw the chunky milk by Mint mobile you
know my family was so horrified and
grossed out and just thought that was
the worst commercial they ever saw yet
people are talking about mint mobile so
does creative really matter you know for
the soup for the Super Bowl creative is
the variable of success the end so yes
it does
the bigger question becomes does
everybody talking about it mean people
are gonna go buy it you know I think
that the industry coming from the
outside of growing up in you know retail
and SMB and and investing and now coming
to it talking about it or winning these
awards or the rankings you know to me of
somebody within all these companies
actually cares about the business right
and so I think yes creative is the
variable of success did it inspire or
make you think that you want to consider
and then buy these products so I you
know a lot of people know that I have a
big passion for volume of content
quantity which our industry believes
means not quality which i think is silly
but I've heard of the whole decade that
I've been in this industry continue to
preach that you know the creative is the
variable so yes I do believe it I
believe if you watch a commercial and
you think that product sucks because of
it that's bad
Hey so speaking of great creative
I love the bubbly Buble commercial and
got such a chuckle out of it and Stacy
here you know is one of the the creators
behind the commercial from from PepsiCo
so you know Stacy it's interesting
because more than half of the pre
submitted Super Bowl ads had celebrities
in them including your bubbly Buble
commercial yet you used humor do you
think celebrity is the greatest driver
of sentiment humor like tell us like
what was behind your thinking in that
and how those individual items celebrity
humor really make your decisions and
where you're going
sure well first of all also I think
creative is the utmost importance in
this and we know when we look at mix
modelling just to build on that last
point two-thirds of all ROI and sales
comes from creative effectiveness more
so than even the media so it's hugely
important that you know we feel like we
have excellent creative at all times and
I think to answer your question about
the brand and about bubbly you know the
first thing is what job are we trying to
do with the Superbowl ad and so you know
a Pepsi and a bubbly are doing two very
different things for bubbly that brand
has been around less than a year has
relatively low awareness but he's really
catching on and catching fire and people
are talking about it and we said this is
the moment where an inflection point we
want to drastically increase our
awareness but do so in a way that's
consistent with the brand which built
which is built on this idea of fun and
playful instigation so when we were
looking at creative we didn't brief in
has to have a celebrity we didn't brief
any of that we briefed what our
objectives were what the brand is about
and then the creative that best got the
brand out told people what it was and
did so in a way that was worthy of Super
Bowl was finding a celebrity whose name
happened to be very closely related to
the brand name and so it was a little
bit of a happy coincidence I think
celebrity always helps in driving PR
impressions talk value but we would
never have done it at the expense of
landing the brand message so as a
follow-up question
bubbly didn't have a lot of
Verte eyes like you said or awareness
prior to the Superbowl you went all in
big with the Super Bowl where do you go
from here we'll have a full year of
support this year I'm bubbly so well you
were using this as a launch platform we
had a full campaign pre during and post
around around digital and social and a
lot of different channels in fact during
the Superbowl we had teams going out in
a bunch of cities and putting sharpies
on our products so that consumers could
find Buble instead of bubbly the next
day and so we had a lot of you know we
had a lot of fun with it and going
forward we're gonna continue to have you
know a full year of of marketing and
advertising on this brand we don't want
to have a boom splat where people find
out about bubbly and then forget about
it this is the beginning of a long
journey and what kind of sentiment we're
seeing in the social extremely positive
extremely positive was 15 to 1 positive
to negative and it was called out in a
lot of places as as one of the winners
from positive sentiment perspective
that's great so onto according to
Twitter 24 hours after the game the
words boring and Superbowl were tweeted
over 70,000 times and the words worst
and Superbowl were tweeted together over
50,000 times so do you think that the
circumstances of the Super Bowl itself
affect the effectiveness of the ads and
the Superbowl it does the research that
you're looking at show a difference
there
yeah a hundred percent I think it
influences the level of attention that
people have when the brakes actually
come in I think the level of emotional
intensity is also just not there I think
if you're if you're in a mood where
you're you know rooting for someone and
you know you're very heated and talking
with your family about it and then you
see an ad that's great it just hits home
in a different way and so yeah I do
think that the fact that the game if
someone was telling me on my team that
it was the lowest score in history for
the Super Bowl
yeah the fact that it wasn't a very
exciting game I definitely think made
the overall advertising just not look as
exciting but I also think that the
overall advertising just wasn't as bold
as it usually is
and so from a creative standpoint
actually one of the things that I was
wondering is to what extent
the last two years of all these these
massive revolutions that deal with
diversity to what extent has it made
brands just be fearful about what they
can say in his energy turn I think it's
a good thing that a lot of brands turn
to comedy and kept it light because at
the end of day it is a football game but
but what does that mean from a creative
standpoint how can you cater to everyone
does that mean that you're basically not
feeding to anyone in particular and what
sort of campaigns is that good for so
what kind of special considerations then
I mean and you can all answer this I
mean that NBCUniversal we have the Super
Bowl every three or four years and we
actually built an AI optimizer to help
advertisers look at the creative and
help them improve it so there are that
you know we look at the creative itself
do you use the celebrity do you use dogs
or children those tend to sell really
well the messaging how long do you keep
your logo on the screen all kinds of
things and help marketers drive impact
what kind of considerations do you tell
marketers to use I mean you can speak
you all of you I think should ask answer
this question you know it's interesting
how you set up the question with dogs
and children
nothing gets more engagement on social
than dogs and children and nothing sells
less product for businesses than dogs
and children so I tell clients a lot
when we first start talking to them when
they want to make engagement or other
metrics that have nothing to do with
their business as the KPI for our
existence I literally look them dead in
the face and go my ability to game that
and be the greatest you've ever seen is
so scary good but you probably won't see
the business result you know that dogs
and children don't sell well because one
of the great things about how Vayner
looks at things is because we have
creative and media under one roof and
the only KPI we trade on is selling
weather DTC on Amazon or their own
platform or doing massive holdout
clusters in Walmart's or things of that
nature what was unique about how our
business was built was we weren't one
discipline or the other I didn't know
anything about the
world when I started it and so because I
was building it for myself with the hope
of buying businesses and running through
it our religion from nine years ago
still to this day has always been
business results and so when we look at
in the beginning of my career when I
would look at reports whether it was
traditional reports or things like data
logics that came along that helped
Facebook justify when I was looking at
internal MMMs and all these things were
doing one thing but then the actual
business was doing another and then the
cliche answers of like because media and
creative were split it was their fault
or that fault it became a very
interesting model as we get as we've
gotten deeper into the process the
beauty of Amazon and direct to consumer
or the sophistication that happened as
we built a big analytics and media
department that allowed us to hold out
you know regions stores locations with
consistency over three years sales lives
so when we look at testing Superbowl ads
we look at we we use blink Andover Brown
and some of the same tools that we
typically use and we look at all the
same metrics and then we add viral
potential just for Superbowl ads so
still brand linkage and engagement and
enjoyment are still the most important
things but then we also add this as
extra metric to make sure that it has
talked value but we would never
sacrifice brand linkage or anything else
in favor of that if that makes sense and
is there any research or sets that you
have that marketers should consider when
they're making Superbowl ads do you know
it's interesting I think one of my
friends companies newer inside was
researching the I think 10 of the ads in
advance and kind of helping with the
creative pre-testing and as it turns out
from both his work in ours what we see
time and time again is that what's right
from one brand is not right for another
brand and so I mean I I agree with what
you're saying about dogs and although I
do remember that the Budweiser puppy
thing is you know I have a good feeling
about Budweiser and I've never bought it
but that's an issue yeah that is an
issue I also I don't drink beer all of
this but if there was if there was a
puppy next to a bottle of red wine I
might have more favorably towards that I
think many ways yeah
what works for bran doesn't work for
another brand and so I think it's not
about trying to find ink our industries
in general obsess with benchmarks and
trying to find these golden nuggets that
are going to transform your brand and
that's not the case I think maybe if
anything from a from both a personal
standpoint and what we've seen from a
brand awareness perspective is that the
constant mention of a name especially
when that name is not known is really
really important actually when my
favorite ads from last year was the tide
ad and if you remember it but basically
it was just the funniest thing or you
kept thinking was this other ad but then
it was a tide ad and they kept repeating
that to you and I came out of that and
again I guess I haven't bought tide but
you know at least that also matters just
think and I think what really is
exciting for me is and look I'm a I'm a
buyer of Super Bowl Phi like when NBC
gets it again these were five million
make it ten because I think they're
really under priced and I think these
done and I mean it I think I think I
think they're grossly underpriced for
the attention
I really do when you look at the Delta
between Super Bowl and then the next 10
most expensive ads whether it's the AFC
NFC championship game the NBA Finals the
Grammys the Oscars like they're
expensive and yet nothing like this is
gonna happen right so I think they're
very under priced but I think the most
important thing that happened so far in
this talk for me is when you said I
didn't buy it but maybe if that dog was
next to a glass of wine it'd be more
interesting there's something called
Facebook and Google and YouTube and
Twitter which actually has remarkable
data to understand that you do have a
propensity to like red wine or dogs or
things of that nature and we can put
those ads in front of you I'm super
fascinated by the unbelievable
capabilities of some of the modern
platforms to do the thing that you just
said that is the most true thing which
is it has to resonate back to your point
earlier what's really tough about
television for me I am obsessed with the
overall awareness spec to the names and
things of that nature my favorite ad in
last 10 years I've stumbled upon was a
Versace ad where the entire ad is just
people saying the word Versace like I'm
a buyer of certain things like that but
after
this and what it does I'm so obsessed
with the fact that we actually now do
live in a world where puppy Redwine gets
in front of you does exist and yet
there's a disproportion and
underestimation of what that actually
means but I think what you're saying
also taps into the fact that you know
there's there segmentation when it comes
to sending the right message to the
right person and then maybe in the
context of the Super Bowl given the fact
that you're reaching so many people at
the same time what you're really trying
to do is either launch a new product or
try to change your brand's perception
but for anything else that's more
targeted for stuff like tie that
everyone already knows about like is it
as effective would you pay 10 million
for that you know somebody said to me
Gary but we have 99% brand awareness
already and I go an 8% relevance right
like the reality is consideration to
your point and I think you're making the
right point the word that you know we
use the word content so much and we
don't use the word context enough right
and I think a lot of where you're going
is exactly right and so for me
you know I'm just fascinated that
one-and-twenty brought up the Denny's
thing because that actually happened
like 7 or 8 years ago yeah it was a
while ago they haven't done it since and
they won't again because their product
sucks
right like they've got like if you think
about what they weren't able to deliver
on they actually got people in so I've
been like watching it for a long time
too and I want to hear a wing that's
relative if it sucks or not know the
audience I think a lot of products that
were on the Superbowl suck no no the
products suck because they were able to
get a massive influx of users CAC but
they weren't able to retain it LTB right
yeah so they basically figured that out
and said we can basically go back for
for scale until we figured this out
internally yeah correct but what they
did worked like like to me what I loved
about that ad and have for like the last
seven to eight years is it worked it was
more utilitarian which I loved about in
which i think is a need within the
Superbowl their unique issue to your
point was the product didn't allow them
to get the value in their LTV because of
the product right a lot of things that
happen in advertising or funny to me we
win and we lose predicated on the actual
thing there's a lot of people that are
part of successes because the
was phenomenal and the advertising was
just fine the product was phenomenal so
there's a lot to unpack there but I do
think context is something that we need
to talk more about and utility to Super
Bowl I think is an untapped opportunity
let's talk about so you know can you
change people's opinions I mean the NFL
they had the their ad for the hundred
years the NFL I'm not sure if you saw
that one it had so many players it was
ranked number one by USA Today which is
actually regular people ranking the
Super Bowl ads do you think that they
with all the controversy that they've
had that that ad has now changed the
sentiment of how people feel about the
NFL okay I think it helped and you know
I think they have a long way to climb
back from but what I liked about that ad
besides the fact that I feel like it was
a little cheating because I didn't have
to pay for a hotel it'll be airtight
everything and it was two minutes long
but it was just fun it was what people
like about football
right it was fumbles and interceptions
and throwing balls and people falling
down and all the talent that we all
loved and that's that's what everyone's
craving from the NFL not all the other
baggage that has come with it this year
and so I I applaud them because I think
they got back to what people want to see
from them it definitely didn't change
anybody's mind who's disproportionately
overly passionate about the concussion
issues the league as or the flag issues
I you know no different than Gillette
like one of the things that's so
important about ads when when things are
going on in real life is understanding
where people sit on issues right so like
if you're a mother of a son who's got
five concussions deep in high school and
it's starting to deal with issues
because of the sport of football that
you're blaming for that that ads doing
nothing for you if you're somebody
completely in the middle and kind of
like whatever maybe it did move you a
little bit and so I think that's what
that's an important variable in those
kind of things I think it's so hard to
change perception with one thing
especially one thing that air is doing
your biggest event I think you you have
to try harder just and do it at scale
and use volume as well as context
throughout the entire year to get that
done
the other thing is I think we talk a lot
about things and everybody here is a
keyboard warrior and a real champion out
there publicly on social media but then
our actions are different right so like
there's a lot of people that say a lot
of things then act differently like NFL
ratings did quite nicely this year
because the games played out differently
on prime-time like so I think there's a
lot of there's the level of hypocrisy in
our society is staggering and people are
tough guys and gals on Twitter about
products and services and then they
spend their money in a different way so
speaking of products and services
Verizon they took a route of
acknowledging first responders and then
tying it back to the NFL do you think
that that made a strong impact for brand
or or did it get where people confused
like how does this have to do with my
wireless service basically yeah I mean I
I think some of those I think Verizon
and t-mobile and auto I think a lot of
those industries are really hard to land
the what brand it's for I thought
Verizon did a pretty did a really good
job and I thought you know linking it to
the NFL players and being contextually
relevant made a lot of sense I'm not
sure anyone like you know in a few
months people are gonna remember that it
was Verizon I think they'll remember the
ad because it was a really beautiful
powerful ad but I think it's right to
Gary's point like unless you have cell
phones all over these days I'm not I'm
not sure it's landing a product message
if you remember its fries and you might
think more positively about it but first
you have to remember it's Verizon I
don't know so we work with almost all
the big telcos I think residents the
only one we don't work with yet so I can
speak to the data itself but what I will
say is that by and large almost all the
other big tell cause aren't making
necessarily this type of advertising
there are law more focused on the
innovation utility piece and the
educational piece for what it's worth as
a consumer I'm actually I've been
exposed to a bunch of theirs their
videos in the series and I've actually
remembered that Verizon is the company
that helps first responders pick up the
call
and for what it's worth it's made my
perception more positive I think there's
a long way to go now in terms of
educating me why it's a better option
but from a perception standpoint it's
worked for me and I love the admin the
thing I love the most about it is that
it actually created a thread for me over
time as opposed to just this one thing I
think if it had been just one thing I
agree with you I probably would have
forgotten about it I didn't love it you
know why didn't you love it I didn't
remember it like I watched it again it
came at the end like I just thought it
was poorly executed like I hate things
that happen at the end like the URLs
that people are trying to send it to you
like ESPN established just 15 years ago
put at the bottom the whole time like
you're asking people you know I don't
know I just didn't love it and I also
think look I'm always thinking about
things like this of like what normal
human being is like going through the
process that we are right now none and
so I'm trying to understand like do we
become caricatures of ourselves because
we're in the bubble and are analyzing it
at a level that is just not real or is
this us synthesizing what people are
actually naturally going through but for
me I didn't love it because I didn't
remember it I didn't remember when it
showed here and even the way it was
executed I don't love the unveil at the
end kind of thing and didn't pull up my
heartstrings not that thrilled
somebody's gotta be the phone service
for First Responder I didn't know I
think you hit on a really important
point which is simplicity so I think
when you have a lot of exposure to a
campaign and you study it and he watch
it a few times it's different the vast
majority of the hundred million people
that are gonna see this have two seconds
they look at it they might chuckle you
know they might feel something in their
heart and then they're on to the next
thing and so keeping it simple I think
could be really important yeah a vast
majority is actually 99.99% right but
speaking of plenty at the heartstrings
it wasn't one of the ads we show but the
Microsoft really pulls at the
heartstrings yet I'm not so sure that I
was left knowing like what the product
was like
it had something to do with video games
anyone want to comment on that I just
think I consideration products are never
gonna do that well at the Super Bowl
I think low consideration products that
need to get differentiated that need to
get launched that need brand awareness
are gonna be good but any high
consideration product that has a longer
sales cycle very tough so can I ask you
a question on that yeah so those kind of
items on regular TBC outside of Super
Bowl I think again if you're trying to
talk about the awareness or get the
awareness it might work
I think from a educational standpoint a
dozen thirty seconds doesn't help with
that I think you need a lot of content
and I think you need to target it at the
right people at the right time
yeah that's why the awareness that's
that's the thing I'm trying to work
through which I appreciate I think
that's exactly right like awareness and
then I'm trying to understand the Delta
of literally every other commercial but
the Super Bowls ability to actually get
awareness and actually be consumed not
potential GRPs and so that's like an
interesting concept of awareness in a
medium that I mean it's scary for me to
think what this audience let or anybody
in America their behavior switches to
amazon prime Hulu and Netflix as just
where you consume period and then what's
left over the last five years of
commercials what's actually being
consumed versus looking at your phone it
starts getting to scary territory for me
for the ability to build awareness but
look at GoDaddy I like I just have to
say like GoDaddy who knew about them
before the Superbowl was there any
GoDaddy in this year's Super Bowl like
legacy expensive I tried and I was
pumped at two [ __ ] Chainz was in the
building but I'm not sure they pulled it
off I would just go back to Microsoft
for a second though cuz I don't know I
wonder if you're making that ad if your
objective is to really get people to
understand what that product does or if
it was a brand perception equity kind of
driving thing that is then supported by
other media that sells the actual
product you know so if you know what
made a lot of people feel something
you know Microsoft doesn't often make
people feel something the way Apple does
so I think that my guess is it was more
about trying to change their equity and
change their perception a little bit not
so much about trying to explain the
product I don't know if this is just me
but I think if you're trying to do that
and trying to kind of aim at your you
know millennial hipster I don't know if
the Super Bowl is the best the best time
to do that I almost feel like if you are
at the Super Bowl you're not going to be
perceived as a super cool brand that
young people are going to embrace so if
you're trying to sell a product towards
that audience I think it's tough
and again like Microsoft has great brand
awareness I think when it comes to
educating people and getting them to
perceive you as a cool brand changing
that perception I think you can turn to
other places for less money and more
Target that's just me I wasn't sure if I
was getting the five minutes sign from
the back she's not Lara do we have more
than five minutes you giving you the
five minute sign I saw you like holes up
like that okay all right exactly
there's QA will be coming soon so in
your opinion if a brand is going to
choose you know one thing to shell out
is it celebrity licensing an iconic
piece of music like Funkytown
CGI god what else is there they could
spend a lot of money on two minutes long
commercial what would you choose Stacey
what would be the thing that you invest
it depends no it does I mean again I
think it you know based on the
development the creative development
process and what your objectives are and
what your brand stands for a brand like
bubbly is always gonna lean on humor and
will more likely use a piece of music or
a celebrity or might use animation but
it depends on the creative idea I think
you do need something for Super Bowl but
I think that something needs to be an
excellent creative idea and then the
bells and whistles that are around it
should add to that shouldn't cover up
something that's just not good to begin
with so I mean I wouldn't I don't know I
next year it could be something
different than I would
choose this year and nada
yeah I mean look if there was a formula
for success I think marketers would be
billionaires and we would be out of
business as a data company I think you
know there's there's different things
that have worked for different brands at
a high level the the things that I've
been saying throughout the panel is I
would use it for brand awareness and I
would try to mention the name a million
times to make sure that people do stick
with something even if it's a thirty
Seconds thought and you know it takes
someone like bumble I think if I were an
innovative company I wouldn't
necessarily turn to the Superbowl for
this I I think there's potentially a
negative brand equity that you get
amongst young people if you turn to the
Super Bowl for for awareness so that's
just me two minutes you would spent the
money on the two minutes in the way you
asked the question yes I just think it's
grossly underpriced attention and then
to everything you're hearing up here the
variable is the creative and and the
moment in time and the context I think I
think that the price is very very under
priced mainly because of the reality of
businesses I'm stunned by how much the
biggest brands in the world are willing
to spend on television outside of the
Superbowl and I'd prefer them just by
superbowl at scale and then take their
dollars elsewhere in some of the context
xual other channels that we've
referenced so I think it's important to
like not take it out of a silo of like
what's actually happening out there and
so what's actually happening out there
is there's brands sitting there and
saying ooh Superbowl is expensive let me
just spend three point seven or five
point seven through the year on
television and I'm just deeply in belief
that they are just getting absolutely no
consumption of that and and and they're
getting no consumption in many digital
places two programmatic banners and many
there's an there's a stunning amount of
money being thrown directly in the trash
and I think Superbowl is not one of
those places and I think current certain
capability of the social platforms are
not one of those places and then finding
the creative that's contextual for those
platforms is very very important during
this time
the haves and have-nots which is why
we're seeing so many brands decline
because when you're wasting ninety five
cents on the dollar you're gonna get in
trouble
good question do you actually believe
that every brand could benefit from the
Super Bowl like let's say Salesforce or
not could benefit from the Super Bowl
it's an interesting question I agree
with where your macro statement is that
there's a time and place like but I will
say this I do believe that every brand
can benefit from so the macro the answer
your question directly in the way you
asked it no I don't think every brand
brand can however that gets in
contradiction with my belief that it is
so grossly underpriced that if they were
to understand what to do with that time
you know I think what we're trying to do
is too much entertainment and branding
back to utility I think that Salesforce
if they ran their ad and said go to
salesforce.com right now and fill this
out if you're in b2b at all or we're
introducing this thing like I do think
the awareness which we I think we all
understand has value is actually there
like to me it's like it's crazy that
it's actually they're sick I don't know
if I mentioned this last year like five
five or six years ago I tried to buy a
Super Bowl ad it was I tried to buy a
super lab because I knew nothing about
buying television and I it was very
expensive for a human it was basically
about as much income as I could have
spent at that point in my life and I was
gonna run an ad and it was gonna be a
picture of my face like I was gonna make
all I was gonna film it on my phone that
was over like hey America it's me it's
Gary follow me on Twitter yeah Ari Vee
and be out and I and I remember like
going through the logic of that as a
human and saying like this is gonna be
the best thing I ever do because it's
going to work I'm gonna amortize out
this attention and value over the rest
of my life I think that the attention is
so under priced in comparison to every
other option in marketing that every
business should challenge itself deeply
to try to figure how about just using it
as a first-party data collector like and
I'm passionate about that
go ahead
I love your passion for the Super Bowl
I would argue so much about television
not be impactful because we have so much
research that actually proves the
opposite including ROI metrics that show
how we can try and don't believe any KPI
and not a buyer well thank God but we
can have that conversation another time
or here I think what people spend other
people's money they spend it differently
and so I think that you know I've
empathy but I'm always curious what a
lot of media buyers and executives would
do if their actual children's health
depended on that media spend versus what
they do for a living and I think I think
marketers are trying to find ways to be
more engaging with consumers using the
medium and a more powerful impactful way
content in context putting yourself
around right you know brands that really
marry your brand to a Content brand you
know
we've done so on fella that the outside
of the Super Bowl would shoot big
investments we've had our on the
television side of the immigrations
media integration so we have a big
partnership with the Ellen show and
we've had an eight-week slide in it's in
show antennas in show and so together
yeah I'm great people are watching that
and then I love it that's where
television started at Sullivan was
brought to you by a town car company
people watch things the format of a
commercial by the way one of my favorite
things that's happened in marketing the
last five years back to your point
countering my point is the way the
television now what sports is splitting
the screen that's been a huge coup like
I believe that's a good move and so I
think Sharon picture is is a huge thing
now is even in entertainment and we're
able to do actually interactive picture
picture and consumers are telling us
they like that we're seeing it like in
red carpet they want to see the behind
the scenes of what's going on and you're
right I mean we all have to get better
at improving the commercial experience
and things like you're doing with Ellen
and integration opportunities are huge
and important and and there's things
like the Super Bowl or the Academy
Awards for the Grammys that are gonna
thrive huge awareness and are around
passion points that consumers love and
you know whether it's like fashion of
the red carpet around the Academy Awards
or music and the Grammys or the whole
pomp and circumstance around America
I think we should talk about things like
Instagram and Twitter 'z usage during
sports and the grammys explodes during
commercial time as a real data point yes
like we like to your point like listen
people have businesses and they're
driving their thing and I've empathy for
that but this industry is really silly
when it talks about consumer centric
because it's not its business centric to
the kpi's of their businesses and I
think a lot of that creates
vulnerabilities that don't need to be
there and I think if anything things
like you know blockbuster are going out
of business and Netflix and Sears and
Toys R Us there's so many indicators
that when you start doing things that
are in your best interest in the short
term financially that are against what's
in the best interest of the consumer
that eventually becomes a losing formula
and I do think a lot of innovation on TV
side would be a great idea sooner than
later you have to do that to engage
consumers so anyone want to say one
final point before I toss it to the
audience or QA Superbowl ads one final
point Gary buy them make sure that it's
the right choice for your pet that was
creative matters great quality matters
yes question
yeah we'll repeat it you have the mic we
can throw the mic and you do
saying is that you have to know what
you're doing the ad for what your goals
are because our off is the only goal to
sell product or is there a longer-term
goal which there's an interplay between
for better or for worse in social media
that is well I think look these are
businesses up here and there's nothing
wrong with running a business and trying
to sell product I think the best way to
sell a product is they actually build a
brand and not the sales centric you'd
like to you know and so what I think
superbowl does is gives you that
potential to do the holy grand the best
salespeople are the ones that built a
brand and then let people come to them
in perpetuity so and I do think the
Super Bowl offers that so yes I think
that's the goal but like obviously you
know short and long term goals matter
and this is what's so amazing I'm
branding and marketing over D are
selling and intent-based Google Ads it's
you can actually build something that
gives you longevity I actually am when I
was saying that you should accompany
that other digital assets like look
social media is great I think it creates
a lot of noise I don't love social media
from Madiba collection standpoint no one
does there's not a lot of room to truly
understand your audience or to be able
to harness that data in a strategic way
for your brand so I think it's great to
think about the higher level stuff and
then with the kind of brand awareness
campaigns but I think fundamentally you
need to figure out a way to drive people
back to your owned and operated
properties you have to figure out how to
have it there right conversation with
your audience and that's really the only
way you can start driving towards sales
at least in our world in the b2b world
hi my name's Lee Nadler thanks for this
discussion let's assume yes Superbowl
okay one of the things that I thought
was really interesting and I know it's a
word that's thrown around is
authenticity
forget the celebrity for a second let's
talk about like actually entertainment
first product explanation I thought
about life did some interesting things
one was up there but the other ones that
were up there with the corn syrup and so
forth of trying to do it in an
entertaining way but actually making a
point about the product but two years
ago I orchestrated the campaign for Mini
Cooper called the five animals it was
basically a program that had celebrities
was entertaining when we looked at the
merits and what is it that people are
saying about our product and how do we
define that with celebrities are
actually also defined that label and had
a mini my question really is and I don't
think we touched on that when you look
at something like Gillette okay the
criticism that I heard and I could be
debated either way and I'd love to hear
from you guys on authenticity what was
the problem that they had by either
having the conversation or did they not
have an authentic thing beyond just
putting the conversation out there and I
think it's really interesting to look at
when you're going to make a big
statement it's easy to say we don't have
corn syrup and all that but if you lad
is going to say you know we're the best
van can be and we're going to do this
and support women's issues in the lab
and then they don't actually support the
women's issues that becomes a problem
and I just want to ask I guess a group
about brands making statements that are
in the social discussion and how
authentic you have to be
[Music]
so I would say Proctor and Gamble is
actually putting their money where their
mouth is
and are leading the charge with changing
the way that women are portrayed in
media and advertising with hashtag see
how much bigger yeah sure so so I think
it could if right then I I pray that
could have been a Miss because people
don't know that if you're not in our in
our business and how do you then attach
so that consumers know that you are
doing good and you know it is tough I
think to link together what you're doing
versus making a big bold statement that
they made and I can see that there could
be a disconnect for some people when
they watch that more pointed whether
joanna or the others just people are
going and they're going deeper they're
going out to social they're doing
research on the brand and what's the
barometer for we're gonna make this
statement and here's our back up for its
real versus we're going to talk in a
social conversation and just have the
discussion I think you know the answer
nobody likes somebody who's all talk and
no action that's just something we don't
appreciate hypocrisy is not cool and so
I think yes it's a really bad idea to
try to look the part and not back it up
because people are looking for that
vulnerability or our judgment levels on
each other and businesses today are
enormous Lehigh and so yeah I mean
that's that's always been a bad idea
that's no different than your product
not being great right like so that's a
different version of your product not
being great yeah it's a book if you're
gonna make the statement you've got to
back it up and you know we America
America is an interesting place like we
don't often mind the crime we mind when
the person is trying to cover it up
right like we don't like to be fooled
and so yeah if a company comes out and
is trying to make a big to-do but then
their actions don't speak to that but
that's happening every day I mean you
look on the coasts the amount of people
that talk about the environment but
aren't willing to talk about that
they're proud of that
their clothes and textiles are driving
some of the biggest damage in our
society like we are one to two issue
people and so like right and so even if
you do it all right is it the right
thing to be about that issue doesn't
decide that as a for-profit business and
I can't think having a purpose in the
world is something that every brand
needs to have but tying that purpose to
a very hot social issue I think each
brand needs to decide that's worth the
risk and by the way did everybody see
the Miller New York Times today I think
the amount of people that saw Miller's
response versus buds move is an enormous
Delta and I think that's an important
thing for me you know I loved it I loved
I'll be on the record saying I love it I
think ads I think businesses need to do
a little bit more of that I think it's a
very poignant put it caught your
attention that they were willing to even
go there and I think back to like us
being hypocrites we don't like attack
ads in politicians yet it's very clear
that it works and so you know I think I
think in what I appreciated was it was
an attack in a very very you know kind
of softer way I thought it was clever
and like I think there's more upside I
don't know how big the issue is pretty
end consumer I'm just not educated
enough on that but it definitely got the
point across and back to why I believe
in the Super Bowl man do I think very
few people saw that print ad in The
Times today at scale in comparison
the Pepsi commercial we're coconut and
like oh my god I love that you did it I
don't know if you fancy does and that is
a truth andhra bhavan you order a coke
at a restaurant they say is Pepsi okay
like that is something that is truly the
world and bill said something about our
brand but you know not everybody is and
and and that's and I think that's where
we get to be to be like I don't know
it's like the head honchos at Pepsi
heard but most of us know Coke and Pepsi
have some similarities like like we're
just so not consumer centric you know
like I'm glad you did that
[Music]
[Music]
affect me and so is that a more
cost-effective way the leverage was
super bold and I can't do a 5 to 10
million dollars
I mean if you can't do the spot you got
to do what you can do about it right I
think one of the reasons a lot of times
there are good holistic you know I used
to always wonder when I first got in
like why are people a little more 360
with their campaigns and that was
because I didn't understand the dynamics
of the creative agency landscape I
didn't know that creative agencies
thought everything besides TVC was
[ __ ] and garbage and not of respect
and didn't mean anything and ask their
thoughts and so you know once I learned
that then I understood I'm like oh okay
they just completely disrespect it put
no energy to it plus the media is a
separate thing to begin with you know
and the KPIs and you know we're not
gonna buy that inventory because it
doesn't achieve the low cost CPM that we
have to hit to get bonus and so like
real life takes over but that's a good
idea you know and that's the punchline
like the right things are being done
because of the vested interest of
partners within the reality of this
business world for brands like jimsy -
that sounds like a great idea
I am disproportionally I mean that I
mean disproportion believes that every
brain in the world should do all the
marketing in-house if they're capable to
being dead [ __ ] serious the problem
is the problem is that I've been hoping
and catching it down i I will never ever
put my financial vested interest in
front of being historically correct
right cuz that's where I think people
struggle and make big mistakes like the
reality is if you're capable the problem
for brands when you play it out is when
the economy gets soft and Wall Street
doesn't like all that overhead it helps
to have so like there's all these real
things but yes I think anything you can
do better for a better price with better
intent is a good idea when a streaming
service such as Netflix or Amazon yes
the writing's on the rights right BISM
yes we had CBS we have ABC Universal
bidding you know getting the Superbowl
and they're investing into streaming
services well what happens when they're
non-traditional
get their hands on the Super Bowl in
terms of how will that affect metrics
how will that affect we devised a
question facts concert and general are
we gonna see personalized content or are
we gonna see easily why that
advertisement invades so you know Gary
said it before in terms of we have to
look with consumer is going and we all
need to work together as an industry to
really change the ecosystem of how
advertising works in the places that
it's available and you also said you
know you go back to the day-to-day
realities of like I need to make my OCM
when I did my PNL and the reality set in
but the consumers aren't gonna stop
moving the way that they're moving and
so you know look there were pictures
Bezos you know with
well and is that something that could be
scary but can they really continue to be
non profitable and and and make money
just on subscriptions because a one-way
revenue stream has proven that it will
fail and that you need to a revenue
stream with it with the price of content
and you see someone like Facebook who's
unwilling to get into the content game
because their margins would go through
the floor so it's really us working
together I think as an industry to give
consumers advertising because three out
of four people who watch the Superbowl
said that they were looking forward to
seeing their commercials it is part of
the pop culture conversation and they
want great creative and they also want
to be informed about new brands so I
really think it's working together to
make it better my take on that is three
out of four sounds right and low
intuitively but what about every other
commercial that exists in the world
what's the polling on that and when
Amazon gets the NFL rights it's gonna
come down to how they want to monetize
it right to your point
how long will Wall Street allow them to
invest and when does the bloom cover off
the rose and that becomes the question
but once you have that much first party
data and behavior nobody here I asked
everybody here to ask themselves how
much they're willing to pay for Amazon
Prime versus what they're paying now
well Hulu when they offered the 99 cents
for an ant load most of the subscribers
took the ad load so because who's
one-dimensional right and who's
one-dimensional one more time how much
is everybody willing to pay for Amazon
Prime which delivers all your products
I'm talking about actually but some
prime the [ __ ] that everybody here has
to buy everything they buy
you know I mean that's that like what
we're having is we're having siloed
conversations and when amazon has last
mile and you can order toothpastes and
get it in in 24 seconds in your door I
think we're having a naive conversation
and when the entire guys if the
terrorists attacked Amazon's
infrastructure for the internet the
whole internet would collapse everybody
is on the infrastructure so like there's
a lot of leverage points that that
Amazon has that we are that we have to
factor into this because they have
leverage everybody here would pay a lot
more for prime because the value of free
delivery across all the products and
service they buy is enormous and that is
just that's just real life and they'll
be interesting to see then I don't know
how much more are we willing to pay for
that core service that is so important
they'll a layer on top of it and so I
mean they have a lot of they have a lot
of leverage
[Music]
and we did it like super old one wasn't
even sold out like the ads on Joe
Louis's fight on the radio were a
fortune in the forty like this is not
that long ago like we're always gonna
move to where the attention is the
question becomes the ad formats the
reason I love the Ellen integration is
that's good you're consuming that like I
think brands should be spending way more
integrating into the actual content and
how networks decide to do that and
things of that nature
I mean Amazon might come out and not
have commercials or who knows but like
what what Amazon has is something that
nobody else has when they have the NFL
rights and you're watching your game and
a player scores a touchdown and you're
excited and the friction of you being
able to know that because something just
happened during their game that if you
just say Alexa order me a Sam Darnell
juicy it's discounted because they're
playing they're eliminating friction
they're gonna make revenue in a way
other people haven't we're not we're not
yeah but like but do you know what I
mean like they're eliminating for like
you're watching a football game
something good happens you're a die-hard
fan and you're aware now through the
marketing and branding that you can just
buy that product through voice like the
what we do all the time is we make
binary decisions without understanding
the other variables that this
infrastructure is creating that's gonna
make them highly profitable their
contents valuable to them they sell [ __ ]
and he see an ESPN don't I think it's
really important to also remember that a
few years ago we're talking about
Facebook exactly the same way I think
there's gonna be a lot of ethical issues
that come into play
consider this idea that Amazon's taking
over the world and they're going to use
their servers to and the alexis is gonna
fully integrate the and in a really
creepy way completely change our lives I
think potentially you might have some
checks about isn't it the government
gets involved when somebody wins too
much yeah but I think it's even more
than that I can do wonder what the
evolution of Facebook is going to be in
a world where the consumer is becoming a
lot more vigilant about what's happening
with their data well if you look at
instagrams behavior we you know the
answer is we go where we value things
right a very different thing Instagram
versus Facebook and the brand awareness
around the issues of Facebook for some
reason don't relate to Instagram for now
I think you might because hypocrisy is
cute just really quickly say something I
think that there's an element of me
seeing that and feeling like I
discovered it and there's something
really special there about it versus
feeling like someone's read my mind and
has put that into my plate in the way
that feels really creepy and intrusive I
am one of the to two to five percent of
people who actually care about other
data is being used because I just know
too much about it but I would say half
the people don't care I think that might
change with time and regardless it
doesn't matter because if I were some of
the people care enough they're going to
change the way everything else works
also consumers are moving the way that
they view traditional linear television
content in a digital format whether it's
a Roku or you made your app and so
they're those products of data and
and you're gonna see a huge shift of
being able to do addressable linear
television like you've never been able
to you before the technology is now
catching up and consumer Nader so I
think it's really exciting times for all
of us but again we have to protect the
consumer and give them their privacy and
be responsible with what we do and I
would like to add that Jeff Bezos did
say that television advertising was for
the most powerful vehicles and he wasn't
a fan and changed his mind in the last
year because he started to invest
heavily and see how it was driving sales
and usage so I think using fear as a
sales tactic is interesting and I think
that is like an important like seriously
I think it's a really important like I
think it's interesting like first of all
everybody just has opinions right and
then things play out and I I have I
value massively people that have
different points of view and think
massively I just I think that there's
ideologies around human beings that
historically humans haven't delivered on
and so that's what I'm trading on but
this may be the singular issue and
that's fine and you know I I think
that's great
[Applause]
hey guys thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube I wanted to jump in
here at the end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
for a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for Club empathy this
project means the world to me that could
really use your support
you